President Trump will meet with Senate
Republicans at the Capitol today to lay
out his priorities for tax reform Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill where the
president's opposition to one proposal
may complicate that effort Nancy good
morning good morning right one of the
things that Republicans have been
mulling over is how to pay for all of
these cuts they want to make to
corporate and individual taxes one idea
they came up with was capping the amount
that workers can contribute to their 401
k's but as soon as that was reported
President Trump publicly nixed it
tweeting on Monday that the 401 K is a
popular middle class tax break that
works and it stays now this bill is
still being trap drafted so we still
don't know if there are going to be
three tax brackets or four we don't know
if the top bracket is going to come down
or not we also don't know who's going to
fit into what bracket so it's really
hard to say right now whether a middle
income earner would pay the same rate
that they do currently or a lower one we
do know that Republicans have said they
are not going to touch the mortgage
deduction or the deduction for
charitable giving all of this however is
moot if Congress does not pass a budget
soon that is a prerequisite for tax
reform and the president urged the house
in a phone call over the weekend to just
go ahead and pass the budget that was
passed by the Senate last week but some
conservatives are balking they worry
that a 1.5 trillion dollar price tag is
just too high it's going to add too much
to the deficit charlie
thank you so much Nancy